hello hello I didn't answer her
phone that's my fake my my real ID's in
there that's my old fake I'm not oh so
you're in possession of a fake
ID oh because you want to steal a damn
traffic cone good
job leave that play dumb games Win dumb
prizes you played a real dumb
game
personal property D you cannot do that I
need I need to ID you I'll will get it
for you how you going to get it go ahead
oh you're a handcuff why because you
stole a traffic cone and and I warned
you about
it sorry hold on that that's all my
stuff will you not warned leave the
traffic
com H hello hello I didn't answer a
phone that's my fake my my real ID is in
there that's my old fake I'm not oh say
you're in possession of a fake ID
oh because you want to steal a damn
traffic cone good
job that play dumb games Win dumb
prizes you played a real dumb game so
you can go to jail for it I told you if
you stole that traffic cone you would go
to jail did I
not that's a yes or no
question yes no I didn't tell you that I
didn't say no
I say
[Applause]
yes
60 be right to him it doesn't need
1019 this to a black
girl never do this to a black girl yeah
yeah excuse me hello that's my personal
property what are you doing stop 60
Central
1095 what that's my personal
property highspeed chases we got a
unruly suspects I will kill that mother
me no do it stay in the BL box I like K
dramatic DUI I'm a pass everything that
she trying to do and shocking body cam
footage hey get on the ground get on the
ground law and crime presents body cam
the place for real raw and wild police
videos you should have seen it it was
good it's on body camera I'll show it to
you catch the action and subscribe to
our new YouTube channel
[Music]
now what are you doing like stop that's
literally my personal property no you
have to have a warant
it's it's to ruin a life over dude it's
nothing to ruin a life
over just a girl
school can I have no can I have my your
down put your fee
down
are fake one of them's an old
id
please you want to start the or just
uh just solely an
underage
oh
nice 60 Cent rep 600 one female starting
mileage 118
987 oh I just spit my good water
that's remember not drink
it I I don't have the money for this
please like I I know yall think rest in
a rich but I I'm
not I really don't understand what's
going on please I'm so
sorry that's like the one thing I've
ever done wrong in my life please please
please please please let me
go like I swear to God I've never done
anything wrong on my life like
please it up
here what's your birthday birthday March
30th
2001 that was just an old fake ID that
was in my purse like I swear to God do
back
court what please what's going
on for the AVR no
M I swear to God like that like you're L
what I swear to God like the Publican
talk this conduct where's your uh
Court tree little thing uh it says court
dates state court
dates you don't have the little tree no
cuz it's it's a
link I can't see I have I have date that
I
didn't what was that did I have like a
court date that I didn't here I swear to
God I paid all my
tickets your location again no no you
you stole the tra
traff after I told you do not sell the
traffic con please I'm so sorry how old
are you I'm 21 all right and you should
know
better dude please I don't I don't have
the money for this please please please
please please County doesn't have the
money to keep replacing traffic cones
because 21 year olds want to take them
home I'm I I please please please
like I swear to God I didn't do anything
wrong like please I'm so
sorry do you think uh you've been on the
influence you made a bad decision yes I
do I think I made a very bad
decision 110% I made a bad decision I'm
so
sorry
please I'm not I'm not this girl like I
don't do this my my parents do not have
the money for this like please don't do
this please my parents don't have money
for this please
don't
do this have pleas do this I think this
is
done how old are you I'm 21 you okay so
why are you worried about how much money
your parents
have because I'm in college like I don't
have to fun and support myself what do
you
mean so maybe maybe shouldn't be out at
1:40 in the
morning you public dos there public can
to S of
[Music]
conduct I can't tell if the battery's
just telling me it's recording or the
battery's D
speak
you
go license be done with it yeah I think
I gave it dispatch didn't
I think all good is she in the
call uh
no I don't know you called her out over
I don't know if I did or
[Music]
not you want to look over it at all n
you have to print the uh PDF well you
can try the jail but it probably won't
print try see what happens you got print
two of
[Music]
them did it give you an error no it just
said now it's just not responding
yeah we do it the other way may printed
[Music]
it match has
been
60 Center did I give you a 27 Georgia
for my
1095 NOP me
a so you said
[Music]
PDF and it ask you like and you hit
print and it should come up like save
and you save it to desktop as whatever
the last two the case number
is I guess it's right
[Music]
there
you think you got to print I don't know
man I'm minimize all that should be on
the desktop you should be to open and
print
it I'm going to hit print do the jail
printer yeah
yeah need EX
it they export it but don't submit it I
mean don't approve it that way if we got
to change
something one
female 60 centry in mileage 118 991 out
at 600
it should be good down we seven
different ways see yeah you might get a
little
manad I do that in
here
[Applause]
get better this time I just can't reach
it under here cuz it hits and I can't
get it yeah I
know did you search up make sure there
was nothing else in there no I thought
you got a good no I just found her ID we
got we're clearly waiting in L okay we
want to thank Morgan and Morgan for
sponsoring this body cam video I mean I
think it's pretty clear from the body
cams that we covered that it's not
always safe out there when you're hurt
it can be confusing it can be scary you
don't really know where to turn well
Morgan and Morgan is actually the
largest injury law firm in America in a
time when you already have so much to
think about they're going to make it
super easy for you they have completely
modernized the process because you
submit your claim you sign contracts you
upload documents you talk to your whole
legal Team all on your phone that's it
an attorney is going to review your case
in just eight clicks also they have
4,000 support staff that can help you
too which is just amazing to think about
and in terms of price well you only pay
them if you win there's no upfront fee
so if you're injured and you want to
join the over 3 million people that call
them every year you can submit a claim
at www. forthepeople.com
LC body cam or by dialing pound law
that's pound 529 on your
phone
no she ain't got no drugs I ain't
worried about nothing
come
on you thought I was playing when I said
I'd take you Jeff if you took that cone
I ain't I wasn't playing I don't lie
come on then you shouldn't have took
it we're
good
stand right here we'll wait till this
side
turn you remember last
two
oh
I me I know it's not going to change
anything but I'm s okay and is these are
just local ordinances no I know I
understand right dis conduct which is
still in the con well arrest my parents
public in Publican talks because you
didn't you're too drunk to make
decisions not to steal cones after you
were told do not steal the cone you're
right you're right you're right and I
thought it was funny and like I'm not
too drunk to make decisions I swear and
like I'm I'm
like I'm so I'm sorry I know it doesn't
change anything happen no what's the
cell phone
number and know it doesn't just happen
if you're going to punish me like this
for
it I mean I I I'm so sorry there ain't
no sense of being
sorry oh I mean I told you it doesn't
change anything but I'm telling you
personally that I'm sorry thank you and
I didn't mean to disrespect
you and I did I I thought I thought it
was F I thought it was funny at the time
and it's not funny okay so you're right
110% 1115 huh dat 11:15 11:15
yep is that failure show here what my
court date no you have a court date
now 9:00 a.m. 10 a.m.
9 this Ro to
I understand I'm so in trouble can you
just write me a t I literally can't go
in there please I write me a ticket you
bond out on
it 226 Central what was my 295
PB right
please
did you hear me on the
radio
clear Mo what what Hancock and Thomas no
Hancock and what's it
right that's right
yeah
get my phone off the dash the
car see it in there right there
is
this what they need printers for what
this is what they need printers for
yeah we had just gotten the ticket bur
and stuff like that a brand new
one officer Pon what's up did I tell you
that I was sorry okay I know not going
to change anything I already
told I don't have a name what is that
Kelly officer Kelly I already told him
that I was sorry personally cuz I'm I'm
not this girl like I'm not that guy was
like let's take it this's run and I got
in trouble for
it well I'll say the same thing my
parents used to say when I was a kid
someone told you to jump off Bri would
you do
it no I wouldn't but like what the heck
please the thing is it's not like you
wasn't told you were told multiple times
no you're 110% right you're right and I
can't be a liar cuz I'm not a liar no
that's one thing somebody can't take
away from you is your character no
matter what happens I know you're 110%
right
351 like please I'm I'm not I'm not this
girl like I can't I
can't but why why am I under arrest like
why didn't I just get a ticket so you
are getting a ticket but some tickets
mean you got to go to
jail okay so why does this ticket mean I
have to go to jail it's just how just
citation
work but like what like I'm just
confused
honestly like I just don't understand I
didn't know they were work like that my
dad's the sheriff I didn't understand
that they work like that some of them
do do they which one is this that's
disorderly who's your dad the sheriff of
uh Taylor County Taylor County yes sir
yeah we're PD not a sheriff's office I
understand that I understand the
difference too then you should have
understood you should have put him in
the predicament now you put him in a
predicament where his daughter's been
arrested because she's stealing traffic
cones that belong to the PD I did it
still in like I mean I yes I did I did I
mean you was trying to go in the the
hotel with it and I told you put it down
and you put it down I said if you steal
that cone you're going to jail I wasn't
trying to go into the hotel with it we
watch you trve enter the okay door thing
I mean I I just don't like please like I
just don't is it Road Hancock ha and N D
or
Han hand h a n c o c
yeah it's just hand
Handcock like I just I really don't
understand like
I'm like please like I I really
I you can call your boyfriend or whoever
I don't want like I'm you can Bond
yourself out it's a disorderly conduct
public in
talkx and they probably after a few
hours o Bond you which means they
release you on a your signature saying
you'll come to this
court